roblox did an oopsie twitch did an ubc
disney did news everyone did
good evening i'm papi borger welcome to
pube news
our first story comes from roblox
pewdiepie
played roblox the other day to stop
t-series
closing the gap over 42 000 subscribers
there was over 120 000 concurrent
viewers at some point
making it the biggest roblox live stream
of all time
i don't know if that's true i just think
it sounds pretty app now i go on roblox
every day
and i check out my latest creations and
i realized
that pewdiepie's account had been
deleted
offensive item reason inappropriate
qd123t 32's place
has been terminated how could roblox do
it
roblox would never do this our content
monitors have determined that your
behavior at roblox
had been in violation of our terms of
service
what roblox banned pewdiepie for
promoting them
how could they do this smns roblox
you banned pewdiepie roblox is biased
now i'm not supposed to have my opinion
but i would never be that biased
they banned pewdiepie just because he
said a couple bad words
disgusting pewdiepie didn't deserve to
be banned
unbanned pewdiepie unbanned pewdiepie
now people are outraged in the roblox
community
and rightfully so i'm not supposed to
have my opinion
but pewdiepie getting banned from roblox
it's probably the most grave offenses
that i've ever seen in our modern
society
95 and i'm not supposed to have my
opinion but i had to do it to see the
poll vote okay 84 people have spoken
i think it's pretty clear that pewdiepie
needs to get unbanked
now i watched the whole live stream and
i don't remember
saying anything bad i mean what did i do
that was so bad everyone that makes an
account in roblox
gets their own little house their whole
little sanctum their own little heaven
imagine that just getting ripped away
from you
so you may think to yourself well
pewdiepie was just having fun playing
with his
friends like his fans there was nothing
wrong with what he did
uh i think i discovered i did some
hardcore digging and i think i
discovered the reason behind the band
look guys i made a new friend
oh you see that he was caught speeding
he went
150 miles per hour in a 50 mile per hour
lane
i mean he can cry all he wants but he
did violate the law
so i watched it all he didn't troll or
anything he had fun with the fans
and other people saying the same thing i
watched the entire live stream they did
nothing wrong
and then people started you know going
into conspiracy territory saying that i
heard from a video that uploading
anything related to pewdiepie roblox
might get you bang
so i decided to try it out uploading a
shirt saying sub to pewdiepie
lo and behold he got a warning offensive
item reason
inappropriate sub to pewdiepie how could
he
so people are still kind of curious like
why like why is that so bad
and people found this post from a roblox
staff from january 9 saying pewdiepie is
no longer permitted on roblox due to
his content redirecting to unsafe and
inappropriate side
channels what the hell does that mean as
well as continued inappropriate behavior
that would not be permitted on roblox on
his own channel
so it doesn't matter what you do on
roadblocks
it doesn't matter what behavior you have
on their game
anything outside will get you banned
links to
sites and channels like what the hell
what sites and channels do i link to
they even say themselves that linked
websites are not under our control
we are not responsible for their content
it says in their own terms of service
which they banned me for how could they
i mean pewdiepie
how could they do this i had never been
this outraged
okay well then you need to ban 90 of
people on youtube like
logan paul and vanossgaming for saying
inappropriate things right it's
basically the same thing
so basically roblox saying that
youtubers with mature themes are not
permitted to ever join roblox is that
what they're saying
it's annoying that fans that just want
to support me
literally get their account deleted for
adding like sub to pewdiepie
my favorite one is this one roblox i met
pewdiepie yesterday on b
swarm simulator greeted him and he got
his
account disabled for saying hi pewdiepie
an offensive item hi pewdiepie
hi pewdiepie my list of demands for the
unban
is simple okay this is a letter directly
to you roblox
i supported you i made the biggest
roblox live stream
and i think a lot of people could
benefit from your game
but now i changed my mind and i'm really
angry
reinstate my roblox
private game thing 123t32
not just reinstate my account but i want
at least
500 roblox as an apology
and i also want a written apology
saying subscribe to pewdiepie to show
that you don't support t-series
in all this that's my list of demands if
you don't follow roblox
you're gonna be very mistakenly you're
gonna be regretful
okay you're gonna be angry at yourself
you're gonna regret this roblox those
are my domains
you have 25 hours next news because i'm
so angry the new aladdin was announced
and uh will smith is just on a career
destroying path at this point when he
sweat
the sweat run backwards off his forehead
just to stay away from his face
was that supposed to entice people to
watch the film
jesus christ what was that what have you
done
to the beloved genie you know there's
going to be a ton of memes there's
already a lot of memes
colossal is crazy posted breaking bad
deleted scene
oh god actual photo of will smith in new
live action aladdin movie
this looks like blue version of shrek
yes it does
upgrade oh go go back it's not too late
to just not do this
please disney please don't do this
next news uh mr beefs posted on twitter
that he got this claim
which was very questionable my recent
tweets have been about my videos getting
claimed i just want to do a video to
give a little
more details basically this is the old
youtube
uh you know analytics which is what i
use and on this it just tells you
whatever musical composition the record
label
you know monetized by copywriter it
doesn't give you any information
which is why i was always so confused uh
if we look this video is claimed by
living on by pascal whoever
that guy is so watch the video this is
what i think they claimed me for because
we were singing this song
and not a prayer didn't use a beat or
anything we just sung the song
um so i don't think that's claimable but
whatever
and then this pascal guy who doesn't
even own the song
claimed it because of let's find his
song
where's his right here this one uh
living on
i think he says living out in the video
so i'm guessing we got claimed because
we said the words living on
i don't know but that's what i'm saying
you say the words living on and you get
claimed
all the revenue is lost from your videos
by those simple two words oh god did i
just say them
like what the hell is this youtube
system
it's insane so it's not even the song
he's referencing
but he still gets claimed for just
referencing
a song like what the hell is
this system on youtube where you can do
this sort of thing
this guy should not be allowed to upload
songs on youtube if this is the sort of
uh way you abuse the system the system
is there to protect people from
copyrighting and up re-uploading other
people's content
this is not it how crazy is this
now grande pointed out on twitter that
methods that these companies are using
outside of youtube are
equally crazy even crazier bringing up
uh
stories like in one case
it told the 61 year old mechanic that he
would have to pay
150 pounds to play his radio while he
worked by himself
it also targeted a bakery that played a
radio in a private room at the back of
the shop
a woman who used classical radio to calm
her horses had to pay a community
centers that allowed children to sing
carols in public
like this is how copyright is used
to target individuals in abusing
copyright law
like what the hell this is the greed is
just unfathomable
i mean this is not about protecting
artists
something needs to get done
next speaking of bad claims
questionable decisions made by ev
decisions being made by everyone not
just companies but
individuals in the community as well
this time just destiny
i mean i called out youtubers for making
questionable copyright claims before
just because i think it's really
important like if companies are abusing
the system
then at the very least we as individuals
or youtube creators
should not be abusing the system but no
one listens
just destiny this time a channel with
1.7 million subscribers
he make dr phil videos which i may or
may not have gotten some inspiration
from
uh but he also makes these very
questionable uh
thumbnails where he criticizes really
young girls
and he adds them in a very sexual manner
in the thumbnail
she's only 13. a lot of people called
out just destiny from this saying
dude like what are you doing this is
kind of messed up this 15 year old kid
called lt cobra uh criticized him
and already the top search you get what
kids are really doing on musically now
without the thumbnail already giving it
away that they're children we also have
kids in the title so justice is fully
aware that he's using the fact that kids
are being very sexual to boost his views
quality mate we have this individual
here kind of moving your hair back with
a teeth out
destiny why is this on your hard drive
travago must be slopped daniel bregoli
exposed
in a thumbnail not to mention the fact
that it says she's only 14. and
lo and behold just destiny took this
video down criticizing him which
obviously he can't do it's just the
youtube system is so
fantastic and on top of that he also
sent a lawsuit
against this kid this 15 year old kid
that made this video he sent a lawsuit
against for being defamatory i think
at least keemstar even pointing out that
this is a fake lawsuit
it seems to be fake and there's no
listed attorney
under that name so it's basically just
fake threats and scare tactics to get
this
kid to shut up from criticizing him just
destiny
did a response to this basically saying
well he called me a pedo
so there was this kid named lt cobra who
made a video on me about two weeks ago
insinuating accusing or throwing out the
conspiracy that i may be like some type
of
pedo or nonce as they call it somehow he
came away with the conclusion
and the bright idea that he should make
a video spreading rumors speculating and
basically insinuating that i could
possibly
be a pedo i think you're getting sucked
this destiny on the whole pedo thing
most people probably don't think you're
a pedophile most people
are criticizing you for using really
really young girl in a sexual manner as
a thumbnail as a way to draw people in i
mean i have a girl
in my thumbnail of this video because i
know that will get views
everyone knows how this works but to use
underage girls
it's very questionable it's kind of
gross thing to do
and i think you deserve to be criticized
for it in rocket science
you know what you're doing and even if
you're denouncing it that's just weird
this is weird
all you really had to do in this
situation was acknowledge
yeah you know what that was [ __ ] up i
won't do it again
and people just can't learn people just
can't face criticism
and instead he just abuses copyright on
youtube which is already an issue enough
to take down this kid's video and even
sending a lawsuit
it's really annoying how people keep
doing this
just stop like this whole thing got so
much overblown
again i've referenced the barbara
streisand for the 100th
time what do i keep swearing and it's
not helping sorry the more you try and
hide something on the internet
the more people will find it just
acknowledge that you were wrong and move
on
it ain't that hard god damn like people
are generally forgiving
on the internet just own up to your
mistakes and that's it that's all you
had to do it's not like
god damn next news to brighten the mood
a bit takashi
who's who's in uh he's in jail right now
i think
before he got arrested god bless him he
recorded this brand deal for valentine's
day
and it's god damn beautiful people how
can i help you guys yeah we ready to
spice things up
you do know you have to know your
partner's limitations i agree
when i was younger i used to make a lot
of stupid mistakes yeah i'm ready to
learn more
get informed help stop violence against
women oh visit a romantic depot near you
and pick up your free pamphlet
thanks to romantic depot i now know how
to treat women with dignity and respect
visit romantic depot rockland go to
romanticdepot.com for directions
finally takashi another fellow man
that knows how to respect whammon he has
so much
respect for women that was way more
impactful
than any gillette commercial it's just
my in my opinion
next news the final news is about helena
live getting banned
uh she got banned for basically saying
there's only two genders your recent
behavior has proven
your lack of understanding what hateful
speech is
and how it may affect your community or
your channel told me
that i insulted the transgender
community
i would advise you to study our tos and
community guidelines once again
okay so what she alleges is i i'm saying
the latest because i haven't seen the
clip
because her channel is deleted so you
can't really watch it
but she said that she was just bringing
up the
ideas around biology i think she says it
here stream
that i think biologically there's two
genders i think there's the woman
and the man that's what biology tells us
i
specifically said it's okay if a man
wants to be a woman and a woman wants to
be a man
you cannot be anything in between i said
i supported the transgender community i
never said i didn't
they banned me because i said there's
two genders or sexes
that's why i got permanently banned from
twitch
are you actually kidding me right now
biology with helena live everyone
now she says so apparently if you get
three bands you're
you're off the side on which i'm not
sure if that's right i shouldn't say
stuff that i don't know
but she basically says that she's only
been banned once
he says several i've been banned once
and warned that way
and weren't that way that the behavior
you're showing is unfortunately not the
type of content we let live on twitch
you look like boobs though you let me
naked tits
but you don't let conversation i'm very
sorry you had to come this decision but
there's no turning back from this point
and we have finalized the process
we hope we can look back one day and
learn and grow from this
i love that we hope that one day we can
all learn from this
you're not allowed to have any
discussions about certain topics i mean
i
prove that twitch staff is filled with
white knights
jesus christ i mean the thing is you
know that this is such a
sensitive topic for a lot of people that
it's like if someone brought this up i
kind of would just go
i mean i don't know why what the context
behind this discussion was i don't know
why she was discussing it
explosives that you probably shouldn't
go near and
lo and behold here's the reason why you
shouldn't
but then again it's pretty concerning i
mean this seems to me
again i haven't watched the footage so i
don't know what she exactly
said but if it is what she says then i
mean twitch seems to be pretty strongly
against freedom of speech if that's the
case
as long as she wasn't inciting violence
or harm against anyone
she should have every right to express
her opinion about it whether you agree
with it or not
it's pretty concerning how these
websites are shutting down
people voicing their opinion on a
subject because
it might offend a community of people i
mean that just doesn't seem right to me
this bending of freedom of speech just
to appease a group of people
we're living in really strange times
right now really strange times i would
be concerned if i was a twitch streamer
to say the least jesus christ
i mean as much flack as i give youtube
at least
i haven't seen them pull any stuff like
this i know youtube still
is working really hard to protect
freedom of speech
and they know how important that is and
to see twitch make a decision like this
is very concerning i would
i would like before i express myself too
much on this to have seen what she
actually said
uh but as she pointed out herself uh
which was are not giving me access
to my vod to prove to them that they're
not
that they're lying they're saying i
don't support transgender people
when i went in the vod in that vault
that they banned me that i had to delete
i said i do i am done at this point
there's nothing i can do about twitch
so there you have it as far as i'm
concerned i think she switched over to
youtube
man crazy i can't imagine i mean
your livelihood basically i don't know
is she a full-time live streamer just
getting banned that really sucks
okay that's it for this week's peer news
hope you guys enjoyed this video
smash like if you did and as always i'm
poppy gloria burger parlow
and this has been my pleasure good
evening good night and have a good
life
you want pyramids we got them oh you're
into castles huh we got you covered baby
you want some pets easy
we got it all this game is still
relevant god damn it
you